oh wait till she's married before she
frees it up two minutes she's had four
already yeah so as far as that one so as
you can free it up for four and she can
fit up for five and six but what she
needs to do she needs to be careful who
she frees up for next time don't believe
the hype as they say don't believe it
and then she wants to free up you make
sure that you date you have
conversations you talk about sex you
discuss about sex and I mean every fit
positions everything because he might
not be right for you do I mean so
anything you want to know about a man
whether he cleans his balls properly you
lost everything before you go and have
sex with them then you're sure so yes
I'm turning there lock it down and